[Music]
hey guys the janaki news is available in
podcast format what are you doing go
check it out links in the description in
cyberbullying news yes
submitted by Susan cyberbullying is
pretty [ __ ] up I was I wasn't sure
where the eff was going like fun but
then I'm glad you because you know I
used to be like Oh cyber bullying it's
like not as bad as real bullying but I
remember when the AOL days you guys
remember a oels
yes I remember a maslow yup so then I
had a AOL accounts and then people
wanted to cyberbully me and what they
ended up doing was they found out a way
to terminate my account to like yeah
they would all go up in groups and like
like make and say like I was doing
certain shares and a lot of people hated
you did well I don't think you were that
innocent right because you said you
would bully a lot of people yourself not
online I did it in person no you said
you said you hacked people you said you
didn't let your [ __ ] online dude yeah
but that's not bullying that's just
trying to get credit cards and buy
things oh yeah okay excuse me I am an
honorable thief not a bully I don't
emotionally damaged people that way I
just take money these rules are legit so
well what I did was I would go online
and we had these things called punters
and then yeah if they have you could
instant message them and then it'll sign
them off I'm pretty sure house boy was
always pranking people but yeah I punted
me that's that it was a good break man
it was hilarious all right well my
mistake you never bullied okay well you
know what it happened to me and I'm like
that's not cool man my account got
terminated for something I didn't do and
they would systematically do that [ __ ]
as a group until I found other internet
friends and we did to them historic just
went nowhere dude you literally made
yourself look terrible
all I'm saying is I know the feelings of
internet bullying and that's just not
nice
you are the bully the person that we're
about to talk about
they'll [ __ ] just kidding no no no go
ahead
continue because I just I'm just trying
to connect I'm just trying to connect
with the people that are [ __ ] getting
terminated accounts online because
people are this is probably happen is
some Instagram kids what is going on
please never defend yourself in court
ever so what if I've learned a bit but I
don't believe in murder but sometimes
hey let me take my federal question not
saying I did do this but I did kill
people five times wait what am i get
charged with milli bobby brown leaves
twitter after becoming the target of a
horrible mini what the [ __ ] how come
that name sound so familiar Bobby Brown
hasn't the makeup Bobby Brown Millie
Bobby Brown eleven how does she get
bullies she's famous no so okay this all
started with Paul does she again eleven
yeah she needs to this is like the most
fourteen I've seen her look and pose
some but I see that I know she's been
looking whales yeah I'm like why are we
sexualizing this little thirteen
fourteen year old she's not fourteen
she's a solid 20 what do you don't know
who's whose fault is that our PR team
her parents her no but it makes me very
uncomfortable
so huh she doesn't look that hot like
sexy she's fourteen until uh over here
what's the word starts with the egg and
oh and the net ending androgynous yes
all right so this all started with this
tweet here by with tweets but his girl
named Kelsey she tweeted I saw Millie
Bobby Brown in the airport and asked for
a pic and she said only if you remove
the hood job and I said it's my faith
and she aggressively pulled it off my
head and stopped who bid that sounds
like a lie
yes and then the print another person
replied you don't even have a good job
one in your profile picture because she
ripped it off of me and I took it right
out here it's a troll this is all truly
yeah but it kind of grew from there how
did it how does it grow from there I
mean it's the Internet you mean some
people thought that was funny and then
they kept saying that she's a hijab
grabber so then that's when it it's
prompted this certain hashtag hashtag
takedown Milly Bobby Brown and then
everyone had their own stories like for
example is one tweet said I'm gonna
share my hashtag takedown Milly Bobby
Brown story I was about to check out in
Sephora using my VIP rouge card then
Milly Bobby Brown pushed me and said
move [ __ ] get off the word get out the
way [ __ ] get out the way no this sounds
like a hashtag shady agents ding you
don't talk about truth or lie who's on
your side yeah sounds like people are
[ __ ] making up stories about her yeah
for sure so then this whole thing is
about like her being homophobic now it
turned into that wow she's a Samba
phobic and homophobic how can she be
homophobic when on the show I thought
she was a boy for a whole season no
Jenna lesbian haircut the whole time
yeah how can she be homophobic when she
looks like a lesbian and she's nice
because I have a friend I actually met
her at the airport and they took a nice
picture together
yeah she only cut the job in half we
should make a hash tag bring back Millie
Bobby Brown I know man that's [ __ ] you
know positivity is never as strong as
negativity yes that's so cool she has
like a like an old black man's name to
remember bro she sounds like an R&B sing
like a jazz musician or something
yeah Bryan finishing the tweets a lot of
people are using the [ __ ] word so it
says move [ __ ] ladies first
then she took my VIP Rouge card and used
all my points and redeem my birthday
gift so that's that one story so how do
people take this as truth it's like she
[ __ ] kicked me in the balls took my
credit card and use my [ __ ]
frequent flyer miles yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
a lot of people it seems like a lot of
people are they know they know it's fake
and they just find it hilarious it's
like Oh Millie Bobby Brown
is a homophobe so then here are some
examples of these memes are going to so
it sounds like anxiety if you're not
good and what if you're not good enough
depression everyone hates you and really
Bobby Brown [ __ ] [ __ ] next one yeah
just stabbed to fact today now I'm
hungry again like they're just using
your images on you [ __ ] up as memes
when I see if bagon I floor it and then
heard you [ __ ] have been talking [ __ ]
on Twitter just wait and see you'll burn
in hell while I rest in heaven dumb
homos
this other one I should I should throw
this on a [ __ ] so like these are the
memes that are that pushed her to be
activated that's [ __ ] up I could see
how this would affect the young person
so that's pretty harsh she's also like
an LGBT activist it's like she wore this
ampersand on one of the award shows at
best so [ __ ] job bro
it's that's pretty harsh for such a
lovable character on a show it's almost
like calling harry potter like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] hater yeah I mean then like an
actually catches wind and you're like oh
daniel radcliffe [ __ ] hates homos
like that's crazy ha just turn into this
tornado what's even worse but now it's a
big joke for everyone and they're just
using her image that she has no
attachment to any of it yeah and then
now it's like she just became like that
means machine she doesn't see it as a
joke which is why she counseled her
obviously yeah I mean it's so hard it's
a joke Millie it [ __ ] sucks though
because she can't even put anything up
cuz now it just becomes a big [ __ ]
all the comments go like yeah because
they don't think it's real everyone
knows that it's a joke now but then now
that she's the butt of the joke that's
not it's only hard because she's very
young if she wasn't yeah cuz they did
this to Chuck Norris yeah cuz if she
made him famous because nowadays to like
evil that Chuck Norris unless in a long
time right yeah but things now they last
about a month and they disappear look
good yeah that's one of my favorite was
only Chuck Norris can dribble a football
Norris he like gets out of a [ __ ]
plane a moving plane into a moving car
and then he gets in the passenger seat
any [ __ ] punches of late
but nothing lasts on the internet long
enough did like if Kevin Hart can like
[ __ ] the hooker and cheat on his wife
did people forget about the next day if
Chris Brock could beat the [ __ ] out of
Rioja and still be [ __ ] successful
yeah and loved by a lot of people like
Twitter is literally like like emotional
thoughts they just they come and go like
that you know it mean so [ __ ] but a
scale doesn't change that she's hurt the
card ever hurts do the best for and I
think that's why I think the Kardashians
are pretty dope because they're the butt
of every joke but then they find a way
to monetize off I think that's where you
start so she started here like getting
round in the ass by Ray J yeah so it's
like she builds up whatever and it comes
back down that she's [ __ ] on stranger
things one of the most beloved shows of
all time yeah and so I think like if
you're a [ __ ] like us like I don't
know if anyone can roast us harder than
you can roast ourselves that's true you
can't roast the [ __ ] roasted
rotisserie chicken yeah we're already
burnt how you gonna do that you can't
roast charcoal that's like getting mr.
Rogers [ __ ] up here and saying that
he's a bondage love loving [ __ ]
cocksuckin they did [ __ ] like that
though I was kind of funny because he's
an adult but still I heard he's a really
sweet man did you guys hear about that
Vietnamese check on Star Wars yeah she
got the same feeling she got bullet then
she calls her Instagram account
why were they like she eaten [ __ ] on
Star Wars or some [ __ ] I don't even know
what it was about but I just see
everyone like everyone at the Asian
community was telling her to bring her
account back and I was like who the [ __ ]
is this and I looked up the drama and so
she was like some Vietnamese check on
Star Wars I don't know how she got
bullied but it was to the point where
she have to shut down her Instagram with
it because what we're character in the
movie or something cuz I was trying to
figure that out though she doing where
the [ __ ] rice hand and the lifestyle
she the [ __ ] woman huh that way
uh-huh I don't really like Star Wars is
such a squeaky clean thing like how can
what I should do I think it's a Star
Wars fan do why you know why it's
because she forced kissed that dude on
the movie that's why you said nothing
yeah that's right is that dude on the
movie yeah that's right which dude ET
no the black the UK black dude Oh horse
kissed him and he didn't want it and he
was already feigning for the other [ __ ]
and that's why I'll watch the movie star
a star course yeah
star core what he saw that star wars
star balsam yeah I love it
Spaceballs Spaceballs that's the one
else when I make a joke about [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh really
baseball's remember space balls yeah
yeah yeah it was funny it was what the
[ __ ] was that about that [ __ ] must be
tough being young and famous yeah cuz we
all started YouTube a little bit older
like when most people start in high
school we started in our like 20s did
you guys hear about the little tape
thing how her brother was coaching her
and then all these videos like that or
all that [ __ ] I was during our break
yeah by the side she wanted to do it no
so so her brother you could hear her
brother coaching and speeding her lines
and then she keeps getting the lines
wrong and she's getting frustrated and
her mom is like saying something in the
back but we saw those videos two ways
you know when a [ __ ] was going down she
looked like a little kid oh she's like
scared yeah that's what I'm saying like
forward seat back because she doesn't
know that blah knows dude yeah it's kind
of sad cuz she's just kind of being
pushed into it you know she doesn't
really know what the [ __ ] she was and
she's so stupid - you are too young to
dye your hair like that man yeah you are
[ __ ] up your hair that's too early
you're damaging that [ __ ] I thought we
were gonna agree on she's still so
stupid to make decisions super
influential yeah so if she sees things
that are cool I thought that's what
we're gonna agree on and you thought
that's what I meant it starts it starts
with the hair though because her roots
are [ __ ] up no I think it's cute
though no best early to be [ __ ] bleep
here no it is yeah you don't you know
you [ __ ] them take your hair for granted
right now dude do you know the leading
on her stuff all the idea or something
oh she's off I do too well she saw the
page she needs to keep the followers
yeah her mom got interviewed a hunch
that [ __ ] she is very determined and
pursuing her dream and they're like
don't you think it's a little
inappropriate no not at all
what's your dream
what's your dream to be famous online or
something I guess not your brother's
name nobody then her and then little Tay
was being interviewed right and it's
like yeah well I'm the youngest Harvard
dropout you know I'm saying and good
like really where it's Farber that it's
uh you know it's a long time ago I went
off a god know a long time ago it's a
long long time ago
[Music]